the big division in most of Europe is
about not belonging but behavior
virtuous
ex-communists countries are aghast at
the spendthrift ways of their South
European neighbors and Ireland
at its current rate of borrowing Poland
may end up in trouble too history is
still a good guide though the cities of
the Hanseatic League have retained the
free trading outward-looking spirit of
that 15th century Alliance and the old
austro-hungarian Empire is still a good
guide to shared mentality bureaucracy
and architecture Czechs get a much
better with Austrians than with Germans
Hungary gets on well with most of its
neighbors despite occasional spat with
Slovakia
Austria used to be a bit standoffish but
now finds its neighbors a splendid
counterweight to those smug Germans
but the countries that escaped the
Soviet empire have mostly shed that old
legacy eagerly Estonia still refers to
its time under Swedish rule as the
golden age even though it ended in 1721
Sweden's other neighbors are less
nostalgic they find Sweden too big and
too bossy Lithuania and Poland used to
form a joint state a 17th century
superpower but Lithuanians remember it
irritably as a time in their language
and culture all but disappeared polls
find that baffling they remember the
joint state fondly and Romania still
remembers the time when Moldova was a
province not a country many Moldovans
find that patronizing Turkey's Empire
Europe used to be huge but like Russia's
it's left little in the way of cultural
or political ties
now turkeys trying to revive its role in
the region especially two countries with
Muslim populations
Germany's traditionally close
relationship with France was once the
linchpin of the European Union
it's gullible ties to Russia in past
years made many of its Eastern neighbors
jumpy but now Poland is becoming the
Germans new best friend and even
cautiously friendly with Russia - the
best friendship in the region is
probably between Poland and Hungary an
old proverb says they are brothers in
the battle and the bottle Belarus is
scared of Russia but unwilling to meet
European conditions for friendship
Outsiders despair of corruption in
Ukraine
Georgia is a stellar reformer but seen
as too unpredictable except by its
devoted friend Romania
and Britain asked so often on the
sidelines as Europe's future takes shape
never a dull moment then on a continent
where problems often outstrip
politicians ability to solve them